bienvenue à paroles autochtone essais
mais sa mort lundi puis cette semaine je
réponds à une question de région qui me
demande pourquoi la ville de montréal at
elle mis un pain au centre de son
drapeau les gens le 13 septembre 2010
est c'était la journée de célébration de
la déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones delà des nations unies et
cette journée-là la ville de montréal a
dévoilé le drapeau qu'on voit maintenant
avec un pain au milieu ça venait
compléter les autres emblèmes qui
représentent les différentes nations qui
ont créé dans le fond la ville de
montréal pourquoi le pain blanc c'est
qu'à une certaine époque avant l'arrivée
des européens
la légende de la création de la paire
impliqué le pain blanc et le pain blanc
c'est un an qu'on voit comme l'arbre de
vie l'art de la médecine chez les
marques et donc en l'honneur de la
nation moi qui est encore situe autour
de l'est de l'île de montréal
malheureusement plus sur l'île
puisqu'ils ont été repoussées en dehors
du territoire
on a mis un pain blanc au centre du
drapeau ce qui selon moi tu es vraiment
fantastique parce que plutôt que
d'essayer de le mettre dans un recoin on
le mit centrale pour représenter
vraiment l'importance de la culture des
marques sur le territoire de l'île de
montréal dans ces régions donc la
question régent
elle est très bonne et j'espère que ça
va vous intéresser d'aller explorer les
légendes des créations damnation moi
justement ceux qui vivent à montréal
particulièrement
j'espère d'ailleurs que vous allez
partager cette vidéo et que vous n'avez
pas hésité à nous envoyer vos questions
je souhaite une belle semaine